look to the most important cities
worldwide that are linked to every
single economical market you can think
about when anything happens everybody
looks at these two cities one of the
ones is New York City which by the way
New York City is now the financial
capital of the world only for the last
few years and it's been around only for
120 years if you think about it New York
City right
the other one is London London is the
financial capital of Europe and it's
number two only to New York City and
it's been around for 2,000 years and it
was the financial hub since Middle Ages
by the way a couple hundred headquarters
of companies that are not out of UK
they're out of other countries they're
based in London that's how powerful
London is and this is why every time you
turn on the television you hear Breck's
it breaks it breaks it breaks it breaks
it breakfast breakfast so what is
breakfast so today in this video we're
going to talk about what is brexit
what's in you purpose of starting the EU
who's in the EU that they vote for
breaks it benefits abstain benefits of
leaving and my thoughts whether this is
a good idea or not and what the
consequences will be if they do brexit
[Music]
so before we get into brexit if this is
your first time visiting this channel
value tell me we are the number one
channel on YouTube for entrepreneurs we
got lot of different videos around a
thousand videos on how to hire fire
scale raise money dating as an
entrepreneur lot stuff for your wife to
watch our husband to watch if you're an
entrepreneur a lot of technical or fun
stuff great interviews as well if you
haven't yet subscribe to this channel
please do so having said I'll let me get
right into it so what is brexit what
breaks it is British exiting EU so
Britain wants to leave
EU and be their own country right now
what is you in you is European Union you
keep hearing about it but you now
sometimes you hear something and you
kind of think you know what it is but
you never question what it is because
you don't want to act like maybe I don't
know this stuff so I just kind of act
like I know what you is who's even into
you I don't even know what's into you
how I did it even you get started how
long have you been around so brexit is
britain exiting EU EU is European Union
so what is the purpose of starting EU
right we keep hearing about it but why
did they start you it's very simple it's
actually two reasons
number one reason was peace because they
had just come out of war again
World War one from 1914 to 1918 customs
17 million lives and then they have the
second war from 1939 world war two to
1945 70 million lives they're sitting on
the same you know how many family
members I've lost how many friends I've
lost how many call it Spears we do not
want to go through another World War
three
so number one reason was peace the
second reason was economical what if all
of our nations collectively can start
working together and creating one market
and this idea was pitched by Robert
Schuman the former Prime Minister of
France here's what he said when he came
up with this idea of ECSC
in 1951 he said the treaty is created
with the idea to make war not only
unthinkable but materially impossible so
they wanted to make it mathematically
impossible to have another war and on
top of that they created this treaty to
create a common market for coal and
steel among its member states which
serve to neutralize competition remember
that key word we're gonna come back to
it neutralized competition between
European nations over natural resources
so very simple you got two reasons one
you got peace the other one you got
economical right so they came out with
the ECSC in 1951 established by Treaty
of Paris signed by six nations Belgium
France Italy Luxembourg Netherlands and
West Germany then that transition into
1957 which was a Treaty of Rome the idea
of Treaty of Rome was to make it a
single market which means you know I can
do business in Germany it's not really
another country you know it's pretty
much the same like yet right now I'm in
US and if I want to do business within
Mexico I have to go get establish in
Mexico then I have to do business in
Mexico it's very complicated for me to
go through it the Treaty of Rome was
look if you want to come to business or
it's easy it's not gonna be that
complicated then they did that in 1957
and eventually in 1993 EU was created so
if you look up when did you get created
the actual year is 1993 right so that's
the history of why they started you and
how they started you now the next
question some people
because Pat it's a simple question who's
part of the EU today how many total
nations are there it's 28 different
countries and here's a list of countries
you got Austria Belgium Bulgaria Croatia
Cyprus Denmark Estonia Czech Republic
Finland France Germany Greece Hungary
Ireland Italy Latvia Lithuania
Luxembourg Malta Netherlands Poland
Portugal Romania Slovakia Spain Sweden
and last Bonelli's United Kingdom those
are xx countries now the next question
is when they voted for brexit what did
they vote like here's what I bought it
like 51.9% voted to leave 48.1% voted to
stay but the question is who wants to
stay who wants to leave because when you
look at United Kingdom it's really four
different countries
you got Northern Ireland which does not
want to leave they want to stay blue
means they want to stay you got Scotland
who has no reason to want to leave they
want to stay because they need the EU
and Wales wants to stay but if you look
at the red England wants to leave right
so that's how was voted by the way old
voter to leave young wants to stay
that's how the demographics looks like
when it came down to voting for bricks
but they voted for it and the vote is
51.9% want to leave the EU okay so now
you may be watching this and well Pat if
the vote was dramatically 70 30 bricks
that I get it but it's only fifty one
point nine percent to forty eight point
one so the people that don't want to
lead there's got to be obvious reason
for it and there's benefits to it and
the people that want to think there's
got to be benefits there so what are the
benefits of leaving and staying so let's
focus on that first thing we're going to
talk about as the benefits of staying
and not breck sitting staying part of
the EU the number one benefit that a lot
of the young keep talking about is the
idea and the freedom to live travel work
retire anywhere in Europe so think about
it living in the u.s. you want to go
somewhere you want to come into u.s. how
hard it is to get a visa right so in
Europe because of the EU I don't need a
visa to go on Croatia let's just say I
live in Crozier I'm gonna go work out
Belgium I don't need to get an approval
I don't need to get a work permit I
don't need to do any of that stuff I can
go work there I can go live there I can
go retire in different place and
don't have anything to constantly have
to worry about passport any of that
stuff travel what's it's very simple
it's very basic to do it the concern is
if they breaks it some of the British
people that are living abroad or living
in another place what happens today
what's the technicalities of that how is
that going to be handled those are some
of the concerns they have that's what
there's some let you stay next one is
it's been estimated that 3.1 million
British jobs are linked to UK export to
the EU meaning other nations outside of
UK what are they gonna do without 3.1
million jobs many EU company
headquarters like I said earlier reside
in London which may have to leave if
brexit takes place because then how does
that work out are you gonna let me stay
now I don't have the whole willing to
work or retire have headquarters
anywhere maybe I'm not gonna be in
London in Romania maybe I want to take
myself back to Germany back to France
back to Italy back to a lot of these
places and that could affect so many
tens if not hundreds of thousands of
jobs in London and UK do they want to
risk that next less likely to get ripped
off this is why it's less likely to get
ripped off because one of the things
about EU is there's a level of
accountability when you're buying the
products from each other because the
accountability the organisation that
holds everybody accountable is EU so
there's less likely to get ripped off
when you're buying a product and
collectively they become the third
largest military in the world
individually they wouldn't be and be a
bigger threat going back to war worries
of another war getting started so that's
that's the benefits of staying and by
the way there's a there's a longer list
of benefits saying I'm just giving you a
few them here for you to be thinking
about now the benefits of leaving the EU
and not staying here's some of them
number one create your own economy
because right now every time UK wants to
do business deal with China or with us
they have to go through EU to get it
approved but if they separate and they
create their own economy they can
negotiate with us with China without
needing ears approval due to trade
agreements that doesn't need to be
taking place now they can do it on their
own right the second thing immigration
this is kind of a technical because
we're dealing with some of this in
America but in Europe it's a whole
different story
what the concern is with some of the
folks in UK that are voting to brexit
immigration this allows UK to choose the
number of immigrants they accept to come
and live in UK rather than being forced
by EU because you know somebody may
watch this and say well that's not fair
because EU doesn't force UK to take
immigrants well if you remember how the
EU works say UK doesn't but if I go to
another country that's part of the EU
say I go to Germany say I go to Austria
say I'll go to Belgium and they accept
an immigrant and all of a sudden I'm
part of the EU that means I can travel
and go and work and live anywhere right
so maybe UK is not forced to take those
immigrants but maybe the immigrant could
start from another country and then go
to UK because that's a better hub in
London and then London takes a hit for
it and they don't want that risk they
want to control and say nope you're not
welcome here this is not you we don't
want you here right and I know that kind
of may sound cultural some of you guys
because I as an Iranian immigrant I went
to Germany at a refugee camp from
Germany came out here but UK those that
want to vote for brexit that's one of
the things they want the freedom to be
able to say we don't want any immigrants
we have we want to have a limit we won't
have a control on who can come here next
one create their own identity they don't
want to be in someone's shadow they
don't want to be hey we're one of the 28
countries in EU not were UK were a 2000
year old Empire British Empire why do we
need someone's help today
we don't need someone's help and then
the other point is that you keep hearing
about Boris Johnson the new prime
minister who's a very very vocal
he says the UK sends 350 million pounds
a week to the EU why are we doing that
that's 350 million pounds a week to the
EU matter of fact his campaign bus had
that number on the bus and here's what
he's recorded to say recently he said no
ifs no buts we are leaving on October
31st
that's what Boris Johnson has said we're
leaving we're exiting and he's the Prime
Minister so having said that I want to
share with you some of my thoughts as an
entrepreneur how I view this whole
brexit EU is that a good ideas or not
and then you can process it any way you
want I'm just giving you my perspective
on what I see happening will brexit so
first things first think about it this
way when you and I are afraid what do we
do do we make risky decisions or safe
decisions right
we typically make safe decisions so
think about you just went through this
war what do you want to do the first
thing you're gonna vote for is what look
I just want to make sure my family's
safe you don't think about vision what
if one day better opportunity better
jobs better innovation but all you think
about is safety for my kids safety for
myself I want to be okay right so for
some folks that are watching here that
living in America saying I don't really
know what brexit is close to you know
comparing it to so it Robert Schuman who
was a French prime minister who came up
with the idea of ECSC hey let's bring
everybody together let's eliminate war
permanently and let's neutralize
competition and bring everyone together
robert schumann is the equivalent of FDR
during Great Depression when Great
Depression took place market crashed
Joseph Kennedy market manipulation
whatever you want to call it jobs
forward all this other stuff FDR came he
said we're offering Social Security
regulated the industries brought down
minimum wage she says everyone's gonna
have a minimum which is the first
president that announced minimum wage 25
cents an hour was the minimum wage he
made all these Ford and all these other
companies raise their minimum wage lower
the hours vacation time all this other
stuff regulation regulation regulation
and people like oh my gosh I feel so
much safer so at that time FDR was a
hero because it was such a scary time in
America and at this time right after
this it was such a scary time for
European leaders that they themself said
man what a great leader Robert Schuman
is he's bringing us peace of mind were
for this and so six countries signed the
Treaty of Paris let's come together and
do this so I fully understand their fear
when I was in Iran in war and we're
getting bombed we're not thinking about
what I'm wondering to go to a great
private school and build a business and
maybe one day my dream I'm all I'm
thinking about is that all we're gonna
be safe are we gonna live that's all my
dad's thinking about
it's safety secured fear we're just
thinking safety right so I fully
understand the reasoning of starting EU
now having said that if you look at 1951
when the European Coal and Steel
Community was created coal and steel
1951 right coal big deal everybody
needed coal let's keep families warm we
got to make sure it's safe we got to
make sure we're warm families right warm
cold great do you know Guardian wrote an
article May 31st of the 2019 this year
talking about the fact that Britain went
first time ever since 1882 they went two
weeks without using any coal and it got
their gas relying a hundred percent on
the gas they got from Norway and by the
way just so you know
Norway is not part of the EU they voted
twice to be part of the U in both times
they said no I think one was in 1972 and
one was in 1994 and they voted for this
right so they're sitting there saying
well maybe today's different times you
know when we're looking at the coal and
steel why do we need that today and when
you look at their steel relationships
for you know Britain where they're
getting their steel from right now
number one country they're getting it
from is a European country when you're
looking at they're saying okay you still
do need some of these countries that
were using for coal meaning Germany then
Belgium then netherlands then spain but
then there's china there's turkey then
you have friends italy so if they really
wanted to get their steel outside as
well they could probably get it if let's
just say they brakes it and some of the
you come country said we're not gonna do
business with you which I highly doubt
that's gonna be taking place so I also
understand what they're thinking about
to say look 1951 yes maybe it makes
sense to be part of the EU 1957 okay
fine maybe we do need to have a single
market fine fine we need each other I
get it and in 1993 EU whatever fine we
created it but today maybe we want to
get out here's why we want to get out
because when Robert Schumann created
this whole thing was about neutralizing
competition and what happens when you
neutralize competition here's what
happens when you neutralize competition
think about it this way Europe
EU 28 countries combined 508 million
people living there right it'd be too
largest country in the world 508 China
India and it will be you for was the
country right us is 328 million and and
they have more access to people to
create advancement right but because you
neutralize competition and that's the
idea there's no competition when's the
last time you heard about an incredible
creative technology company or even
community of that being created in the
EU when's the last time you heard about
it now somebody made sure what about
Spotify you know know what about the guy
you know
Spotify think is Sweden or the Siri guy
is he created a technology for an apple
from there yeah but okay great
go look at some of the major companies
in EU they're companies that have been
around for a while it's oil companies
its companies that are like oh I know
this company but it's for such a long
time so where is the innovation why is
that not taking place maybe because we
need competition here's another point
for you that EU forces the employer to
give every employee five weeks of
vacation time not including the national
holidays which is another two weeks so
five weeks not including the national
holidays which is another two weeks
that's seven weeks so take seven weeks
out of 52 weeks out that loses momentum
which in u.s. we don't do five weeks we
do two weeks so give that additional
three weeks times your population of
people living there
how much more opportunities there for
innovation so maybe Boris Johnson is
saying look I don't want to deal with it
with her like that right I just don't I
want to see us competing for our stuff
I'm making a name for ourselves now the
other side is also to keep in mind that
if this does take place the top
contributors right now to the EU number
one is Germany they put in 21 point 1 1
percent of the entire budget then it's
France 16.4 then it's a totally thirteen
point six four then it's UK thirteen
point oh five so UK's number four in the
amount of money they put into it right
you've heard Boris Johnson say they paid
350 million pounds a week to the EU so
you hear a number like that thirteen
point four all five percent that they're
putting into it fair watch this if UK
pulls out and they say we're out of
bricks we're out of it I'm about
everybody's saying they're doing it
because we're Boris Johnson a saint but
if you case actually officially out
that'll cost Germany an additional four
billion dollars billion euros per year
and France another three billion and it
will cost Italy another two and a half
billion per year to fund into EU so what
does that really mean here's what it
could really mean a couple things one so
UK breaks it takes place they leave okay
all of a sudden it's like you being at a
bar and you typically shared the tablet
everybody and one of the guys that pays
the most he leaves now you have to pay
even more for everybody so you have to
sit there and say look we're Germany
we're big we're powerful you know what
guys we're out as well we'll help you
guys out and everything but we want to
leave as well if Germany France these
guys decide to leave now it's a whole
different thing now you talk about EU
goes from being 28 to possibly a lot
less than that then there's gonna be a
lot of challenges for funding and money
and because the smaller nations cannot
afford to put a lot of money into so no
one really knows what could be taking
place and a final thought to be thinking
about because if you go and watch what
the grandson Churchill's grandson said
they asked him they said if your
grandfather was here right now what
would he say about brexit he says he
would absolutely be against it now some
people say because Boris Johnson wrote a
book about Churchill and one of the
things that he and I hear in a Churchill
both have in common is their war
journalists and they both became PM's
and they're both pretty hated type of
personalities not everybody loved
Churchill by the way Churchill is a guy
that you counted on when war happened to
go up against you know the Germans and
all these other things I was taking
place out there during World War two but
they didn't like him too much right
cause he has strong opinions Churchill
once was for the United States of Europe
right but he was also the same guy that
says we are for Europe but not of it
meaning were for Europe well we're not
of it we stand alone we're our own
nation we have our own identity so
there's contradictions and a lot of
ambiguity in his message on what he said
some people said he wouldn't be for
breakfast some people said he would be
but here's some world a story what I can
tell you is the following
times have changed before was a lot of
manual labor a lot of manual labor who
can work hard or a lot of companies the
countries were rich because of natural
resources pure luck you have oil you're
rich okay good for you
you don't know what to do with it right
there's a lot of that going on today I
think it was TEDx conference that was
ten years ago and they said the number
one resource right now everybody wants
his data is data data data everything's
about data you got data you're winning
and today it's about data it's no longer
just manual it was thinkers so maybe you
case sitting there saying look due to
globalization we don't feel like we need
you like we did back in 1951 we don't
feel like we need you like we did 1957
we don't even think we need you at like
we did in 1993 cuz globalization with
internet all this stuff wasn't really
here like it is today we think we can do
it on our world but regardless of all
this stuff taking place there's one
thing I can't tell you typically there's
a lot of war that takes place due to
ideologies right you know we believe in
this we believe in this no you're wrong
let's go war right and all these wars
take place today
the the market is so fickle because of
what's going on with trade war with
China
what's going on with wall Mexico trade
there
what's going on with brexit if that
happens UK's gonna take a hit and London
is the number two financial you know
capital of the world
there's a lot of things that are cooking
right now a lot and it can either go
good or it can either go very bad but
it's not gonna be you know staying in
the middle here there's gonna be some
major shake-up and again I'll give you
the good news and bad news
the bad news is some people are gonna
lose big time and the good news is some
people are going to make big time it's
just about how you position yourself so
again these are my thoughts as the
entrepreneur these are my opinions I'm
giving you my feelings based on what I'm
doing my research on I'd love to hear
from you comments below by the way if
you watch this video you liked these
approach there's another video I did on
Venezuela you if you want to find out
how I feel about what's going on with
Minnesota here's one video to watch with
Minnesota and the other one video I did
on China the us-china trade where you
can watch this one but either one of
these videos all have to do with the
economy and how the market could take
the hit because every one of the
Venezuela's oil China's trade this is
breaks it it's like a soup with so much
mixture that we don't really know what's
gonna happen it's just making sure we're
prepared for all of it so again haven't
watched a venezuela video to china video
click on these links go watch them and
if you haven't subscribed please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye bye